and we are live
all right
let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your favorite podcast
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
ripping with a gripping live once again
every Tuesday
still doing it got a lot today I had
another Eevee car disaster I went to
Montana it snowed in California a
cheerleader performed by herself Girl
Scout cookies there's a scam
that
and many more
so once again
welcome back
[Music]
yeah riffing with Griffin baby what's up
everybody welcome back to River with
Griffin appreciate y'all
as always you know let's subscribe
share hit the notifications so you get
this every time that it comes on
everybody
um you know I'm on Twitch you know what
I'm saying I like I like doing my twitch
I'm on my twitch daily so check me out
on there extra content on patreon or if
you just want to just support that's
just a way of support same thing with
being a twitch subscriber or a YouTube
member all you guys I appreciate you for
being here as always welcoming back to
referend with Griffin so
um this week I will be in Vegas at the
Jimmy Kimmel comedy club in Vegas from
the second to the fifth so come check me
out at the Jim o Kimmel Comedy Club
Jimbo camo I didn't say that 50 times
fast Jimmy Kimmel comedy club in Las
Vegas come check out your boy uh thanks
for being here on Griffin with Griffin
as always you know you guys you know you
leave comments
so let's open up with some comments uh
from jaw Choi said yeah the KD move made
the NBA less cool for sure uh yeah
something from a discussion from last
week uh just talking about the NBA I
will be talking about the NBA moving
forward a little bit more here
um
you know what I mean and so
you know let me I gotta I it's funny
because I'm looking at some of the
comments and this is one of those like
well hide user from from Channel you
know it's like I mean I don't understand
why people anyway
um uh Belinda thank you Belinda cross
street uh stay real both of you you do
not look or act fake for to me stay real
appreciate that appreciate that
um Steve back let's be honest all sports
have not had the same effect they used
to have we need to stop watching these
pointless things and connect more as
people uh you know thanks for that
comment Steve but I disagree with you
because actually going to a sporting
event is a great way to connect with
people this is I used to love going to
the Clipper game you get to know the
people around you and there's something
communal about everybody enjoying this
thing together 20 000 people who are
like cheering and you know they're
they're so I disagree with you on that
same thing with going to a movie theater
even in a dark theater there's something
about share it a shared experience uh
when you're watching a movie together
and you hear the reactions from people
so I disagree with that
um
let's see uh I don't even know how to
say this person's name JLS JL song ton
ton two it's a weird name I wish you
guys would just use your name lion's
mane is the new trend now for health
researching and want to start talking
taking it to like hearing health things
you're taking and doing love your
relationship with Rachel thank you
appreciate that
um
JC Arnett Arenas JC Arenas facts the
player movement to make these all-star
teams made me stop watching and I'm from
Miami and was a big Heat fan but I don't
know not the same yeah man you know and
thanks for all the comments guys if you
want to leave a comment go leave a
comment uh you know I like when people
leave comment Jeff Bridges thank you for
the the uh Super Chat for everybody
listening live or if you're not if
you're listening later you know I do
this live on Tuesdays but if you just
like listening in your car I appreciate
you guys too your truckers you people
that you know have a a some of those
jobs where you know you can just put on
headphones and do whatever the task is
that you're doing and you like listening
to me I appreciate you and I'm here for
you every week and the people that
support the show too so Jeff Bridges
thanks for that um super chat right
there man I appreciate that everybody
that wants to support me I appreciate it
so yeah man you know so like the NBA
yeah I just I don't know it's just that
the sports in general is just kind of
down for me but the NBA they're dealing
with some stuff man they gotta really I
don't know what it's going to look like
in in you know in the next like few
years but we'll see we'll see how that's
going but we're not talking about the
NBA today
um so hi what's been going on uh you
know last week before I left to go to
Montana and I got to tell you about
Montana Montana was crazy
um there was like a snowstorm or
something you know it was really it was
really crazy uh you know like here's and
I got my my thing working here my uh
yeah baby so apparently there was like
some snow there was a snowstorm because
it hailed it was crazy
um
Rachel and I you know Rachel's like just
she's screaming I mean like I hear like
all this noise right
like look at this picture it's from Napa
it's under a blanket of snow Southern
California's got his first blizzard
warning in 34 years I mean we got a
blizzard warning I mean that's that's
Armageddon for La we don't we don't do
blizzards but it hailed and it was like
these little I don't know if you know
what hail is but it's like frozen water
it's not like snow it snows different I
mean I'm from California what do I even
know about this but
hail is like is it like little rocks of
water of ice that are just falling
so we got this balcony and then this
hail and Rachel's screaming at me and
she's like you gotta come see this you
know and I was like in the middle of
gaming and she's like I was like babe
it's fine it's just hail she was like
calm down now you know so I go running
upstairs and she's like just with a big
smile on her face because it's just it
was it was fascinating you know I I
wouldn't have wanted to be on the road I
didn't really hear about if there was
any like
if there were any accidents or anything
like that on the on the roads in LA but
it was crazy
anytime we get some kind of like extreme
weather in California we don't even know
how to act man so I don't know I don't
know what's going on with the weather it
seems like it's global cooling you know
what I mean it's like it's been so cold
like it's been really cold here in Los
Angeles for us I don't know about you I
don't know where you guys are at but
yeah California it's been kind of chilly
out here so we'll see what's going on
with the weather man you know it's like
what's we hear about global warming it's
like are we affecting the weather where
it's going to be like where it's usually
hot it's going to be cold where it's
usually cold it's going to be hot I have
no idea but like we don't know how to
deal with like extreme weather in La you
know we just like things shut down like
when I go to like some cold weather town
and like it'll be like you know 10 below
or something and then I'll say like oh
man is this going to affect the show is
anybody going to show up and they're
like oh man that's when people really
show up because they don't want to be
home anymore and there's nothing else to
do they're going to sit inside it's a
warm building with other people and just
enjoy themselves so it's just weird
because in La it's like a whole
different thing man sometimes people in
La people just stuff just closes down
man closes down I want to thank other
people out in uh Great Falls Montana
that came out to the show at the
Newberry uh shout out to you know that
was it was actually a great show it
almost didn't happen y'all it almost
didn't happen speaking of the weather in
California so
it was just a one night show right so
I'm supposed to go Saturday and so
usually I like to go a day ahead of time
but I saw that they have direct flights
to not direct flights but they have
flights from the west coast to the you
know because Montana is not necessarily
where you're going to New York or
something where you're going to lose a
lot of time so I could leave here at a
reasonable hour in the morning and I
could get to Great Falls Montana around
1ish and then that means I have the rest
of the day to kind of chill and relax
then do the show and then fly home the
next day right so it's like the middle
of the night middle of the night uh not
even the middle of the night but I'll
say like 2 A.M ish I get a text message
from United Airlines and it's like hi
your flight has been delayed but it
wasn't even just delayed the sucker was
delayed eight hours
all right so a flight that was supposed
to leave La at say 6 a.m fly to Denver
and then Denver to Great Falls Montana
they're they're saying my Denver flight
is eight hours delayed so I'm like what
so I called United and I'm like yo
what's going on and they're like yeah
I'm so sorry you're like you know and
then all the other flights were booked
because a lot of flights were canceled
because what it is is the inbound
aircraft couldn't get into LA because of
and be there overnight but that's how
that would happen because of the extreme
weather in L.A so I'm sitting here like
all right so what am I supposed to do so
so I go okay well let me just check and
see what I can do so I'm looking I can
hang up with that person and then I'm
looking online and I'm like man there's
literally no way to get to Denver to get
my other flight I'm like this is going
to be the first time ever in my career
that I've missed this show that I
couldn't make it to the show so I texted
two people there was like two contacts
so I text them both at the same time and
I'm like yo listen and my flight was
canceled and I just don't think I'm
gonna make it I'm really sorry I don't
know what to do so then I call United
back I cancel my flight get my money
back and I'm just sitting here with my
wife I'm like I guess I'm not going
tomorrow and she's like Yay you know so
we're just kind of laying in bed
chilling and it's late and we fall
asleep and I wake up
just casually wake up around
you know 7 45
uh my the my manager's assistant like
she she she knew what was up I told I
had hit her up in the middle of the
night she was like I let them know and
then I'm like okay cool well I guess I'm
just not gonna make it and so then
around eight I just I don't have my
notifications on on my phone I just
happened to look at my phone and I see a
bunch of text messages from the people
okay and they're like
um are you still at the airport uh you
know we found this fight in that flight
and you know so they want me to get now
they want me to fly to Bozeman Montana
and they would pick me up from Bozeman
and take me to Great Falls and it turns
out there's like direct flights to
Bozeman which I I didn't even know like
why would you but it's because of
Yellowstone the show Yellowstone and
during the pandemic a lot of people
actually moved from LA to Bozeman and so
Bozeman has become this like booming
town the the the the property values
have skyrocketed and the rents have
skyrocketed so Bozeman seems to be the
place to be in Montana so anyways
the um
the uh so all right it's like 8 15 now
okay and I'm like uh oh because they
call me and they tell they they they're
hitting me up and and I'm finding out
they're like listen we do not want to
cancel the show people are actually
flying in to see the show people are
driving from Canada to see the show and
I'm like oh man okay I don't want to
like leave people hanging like that
right so I go all right let's uh I I say
okay I will get I will I will get on the
road so I look at United's thing and I
see that there's actually a flight
that will get me into Bozeman at a
certain time but the flight leaves
at 9 35 it's 8 15. okay I was packed I
was ready to go so I just I was like
well I guess this is it
you know what I mean so I booked the
flight
I got my bag I get in the car I drive my
car to the airport I park my car at the
airport like right you know sixty
dollars a night for parking and I just I
get on this flight the lady picks me up
great they're great people all right
um picks me up and then we fly we drive
two hours to to Great Falls
and then I'm staying at this little
weird hotel that has a bar
that has like it's freezing okay and
there's a bar that has like a big
swimming pool like a big tank connects
so there's like a big open window and
there's a mermaid
a girl dressed like a mermaid is
swimming in this pool for you know for
the the people in the bar to see so that
that was crazy
so you know it's just like weird retro
Hotel like they they called it up
retrovation because they made the hotel
look like it was a 70s hotel which
honestly I don't get uh because I'm a
creature of comfort you know but it was
nice everybody was nice you know I
remember when I flew into Bozeman I was
like I was looking around as I was
walking the airport and I was like wow
this is a different world like literally
everybody was white okay like
everybody was white
until I found I saw one dude working at
a coffee place
is this black dude it was crazy because
it was like everybody was white and then
the one black guy I saw he was like tall
skinny big ass afro and I was like oh
okay so he was compensating for it all
but it was like but the people were very
like I say everybody was really nice uh
the drive was cool Montana is a really
beautiful state
uh the Sip and dip that's the name of
the place classic Montana spot it's
called the Sip and dip
get it because it's the dip because
she's swimming
um but yeah so shout out to Great Falls
Montana the whole thing was dope had a
really good time so I want to just thank
everybody that came out to the show and
remember this week I will be at the
general Kimmel comedy club in Las Vegas
so if you're in Vegas this weekend you
have plenty of chances to to come watch
me
okay
um I had another Eevee car disaster man
and I've talked about this on the
podcast before and it's actually the
same thing so I had a show in Las Vegas
not Las Vegas in San Diego so I had a
show in San Diego last week Wednesday
night it was just gonna be one night a
drive up and I've done this before
I drive my car down when I'm staying a
weekend and then it's like a big hassle
because I have to find a place to charge
my car and then you know you're driving
around there it's like you want to get a
full charge so you got to find a place
you can charge overnight so I like to
stay at a hotel that has an EV charger
but then you have to like maybe it's
taken already or maybe it doesn't work
right
so I go you know what I'll figure this
out Rachel says to me I think you should
take my car and I go nah I got it
boy was she right
so I drive down to San Diego and I go
early because this is what I told myself
I wanted to do I'm gonna drive down
there early
maybe find an EV
charge the car before the show
at a fast charger which for my car is
going to take like
30 40 minutes depending on how much
charge I had left by the time I got to
San Diego
and so I I I find a spot and then here's
the first part of the problem man which
this whole idea of all of going all
electric into cars or even 50 electric
by 10 years from now whatever the hell
they're trying to do
these EV Chargers have to work
it can't be a situation where you get
there and
five of them are out of order because
this is what happens on a regular damn
basis
Electrify America this is I'm calling
you out Electrify America is one of
these companies
get your [__] together
if I am stopping to charge my car
it's because it's needed
like this is almost an emergency
situation
I pull up to this place there's somebody
parked in one they're sitting in their
car so obviously it's working another
person's like not in their car they're
kind of looking at the machine but it
looks like they've been there for a
little while this one got to my right he
pulls out takes off so this other guy
pulls out I'm thinking they're both done
so I pull out it was easier for me to
pull into the car into the one that the
guy just left
they're the one on my left right and
then he pulls into the one that then
this guy pulls into the other one and
I'm like whoa what's going on here and
that guy's yeah that one doesn't work
man you got to call customer service and
I'm like what so
I call customer service and you know
they're like hey yeah I go you tell them
you tell them the number I'm at the
station two seven five five whatever it
is right and they're like oh they're
looking on the machine yeah it looks
like there's five Chargers there and
she's like yeah it looks like yours is
supposed to be working I'm like it's not
working
and the one next to me doesn't work like
like all of them don't work except one
you know what I'm like what the hell and
then they're like oh sorry we're so
sorry like you know what [__] you're
sorry that's how I feel about it I don't
care about your sorry
I don't want to hear sorry like this
this is the service you provide
you provide Electric Power
for electric vehicles
the electric outlets need to work
all the time not some at a time
all of the time
you don't you rarely go to a gas station
and none of the pumps work you know what
I mean maybe one of them's out of order
but the rest of them are working because
they know that this is the business that
they're in
selling gas EV is electric vehicle
so I'm like what
I
so then I'm like okay well what do I do
so then I look I have like 10 apps
there's so many electric car charging
apps so I go all right boom I'll find
another one and they go okay well we'll
give you a free charge you know just
call when you pull up to the thing and
we're so sorry so now I gotta drive
around again and find some other place
you know and it's like I got maybe like
80 miles left on my car and so I'm like
okay I find a new place and I I charge
I'm sitting there but now I'm realized
I'm real early for the show I go eat I
go get a nice dinner uh you know I'm
treating myself and then I'm kind of
like looking around driving and then
it's like I get my car down to like 200
miles
by the time I because I didn't do a full
charge so by the time I I'm parking in
front of the the venue for the show my
car's at like 202 miles all right so I'm
thinking it's 100 miles to La I can make
this now here's my problem one with
electric cars
fix the speedometer fix the the the
readout man like don't tell me I have
200 miles if I don't have 200 miles
like
when I get in my car and I turn on the
the
AC
I'll see droppage in mileage so I think
okay so they're letting me know that
because I have the AC on I'm losing this
amount of miles but it's not accurate
like it's never accurate
so I head home it's late now it's over
so I'm driving home late man you know it
was a long show
so I'm headed home and then like it's
like 200 miles okay it's you know I have
like a hundred and something miles to
get home
you know and then it starts to to like
the the numbers get getting closer as
I'm driving so it's like you know it
says you have 200 miles left
uh and you have you know 80 miles to go
and then it's like oh you have
185 miles left and you you know what I'm
saying like it kept like the numbers
kept getting closer and I was like oh
man
it got to the point where you man I'm
like
15 miles from home
and this sucker is telling me like
you only have 30 miles left and I'm like
15 miles to go I'm like whoa and it just
kept getting to the point where
I had two miles left on my car and I was
nowhere near
I'm exiting the freeway and now the
anxiety and stress of I'm gonna be at
zero and my car is just gonna be
completely dead
I pull I finally get to Electrify
America another spot that I know is
right by my place
I pull in because the car even says to
me the car is flashing like the car goes
into low power mode the car goes to the
point where I can't even go above 20
miles per hour you know what I mean and
I'm like in the street I get to a red
light I look around I say I run this red
light I'm like I can't even stop I can't
risk it I get I make it my car's at zero
y'all zero I'll pull into the Electrify
America guess what yeah
it don't work
so I call them and I'm just like it is
the middle of the night
I am in an emergency situation
and so let me reset the device sir and
then like I tried to plug it in I told
him I had an account and the lady was
like oh we'll put this free thing on
your account of course it's not on the
account I have to call it's like I'm
sitting there you know and then I also
have to go to the bathroom bad
like a 50 year old man I have to go to
the bathroom where I have no control
over holding this there's a lady next to
me in her car she's like plugs her car
in fine and she's sitting there like it
looked like she was having a hassle too
so now
that the thing finally turns on because
I'm thinking have I ruined my car is my
car not even gonna take the battery now
like it's like you know
finally get it to work
and now I'm standing here and I like I
have to pee it's the middle of the night
so I just I'm on my phone and I just go
over to a bush this lady sees me I don't
know nothing else I could do you know
what I mean
I finally then I sit in my car and I'm
just like
and I just thought what a nightmare
like we're not ready for this yet
we're not ready for electric vehicles
we're not ready yet the infrastructure
is not in place nothing's ready yet
unless you have a car that goes over 300
miles and a true 300 miles
like I'm getting a new car I'm getting I
I actually signed up I've signed up for
the Fisker so I'm getting a Fisker ocean
I've already got you know they keep
sending me the information you know your
your build lock and all this you know so
I'm getting this like
I'm getting this like blue I can
actually show you guys
um
you know I'm getting this blue
Fisker ocean it's like a weird color
because I was like you know what let me
not I don't wanna I don't want to do
like just the same thing everybody else
gets you know so I was like you know
what let me get let me let me get this
new this new new you know what I mean
and then so but like I'm just telling
you I do not think
I just do not think that we're ready
because if the companies that provide
the electricity if they're not going to
be up to Snuff at all times like what
are we doing you know
Like It's gotta be ready man it's got to
be it's got to be available and ready to
go and it just really I don't know it
just it kind of ticked me off you know
oh let me see if I can get a picture of
this reservation here's my reservation
oh my build see they had this thing that
oh your build is locked
um so I can't even I can't even see it
it's not even going to show it to me let
me see wait this might be it I think
it's loading up
you know and then like Okay so
like I'm saying I got distracted I'm
sorry the you have to
be able to go
like I said minimum 300 miles
like my car even from the beginning was
never 300 miles but I got it in 2019
this is still fresh and new for these
new car companies
like anything less than 300 I'm telling
you right now do not get that car do not
get it unless you're just you're only
driving it around the city
okay unless you're only driving it
around the city
um here so let me show you guys but you
guys are probably gonna talk trash
you're not gonna like it yeah
so there's my car baby
wait how do I make it turn uh you can't
make it turn oh here we go oh look at
that look at that see people that are
listening so I got this sort of bluish
color
it's blue with it with white interior
and like white trimmed rims but yeah but
this is what the car looks like
you know
that is what the car looks like
so I don't know if you uh like a
um no uh Eric uh whatever your name is
I see you in the chat first world
problems it's not first world problems
man you could get a a Hyundai for very
cheap less than 30 000 uh dollars uh
there's a there's a very inexpensive
electric cars out there right now for
people who uh you know and they go good
they get good mileage uh Hyundai has
some good ones Toyota has some good ones
nah man this ain't a first world thing
my car is a first world Pro thing I get
that but what I'm telling you is there
are other cars out there because that's
because they're trying to make
affordable electric cars and what I'm
saying is what's gonna suck about it is
for people who are not first world
problems people you know if if all you
have is this electric car you're gonna
be in a bind you're gonna be in a bind
man because you're gonna be out
someplace and you're gonna need to
charge and you're gonna have to sit
there for 15 to 20 minutes to charge and
you're going to be looking and you're
gonna be like oh wow this isn't working
so now you got to get your apps out
because it's all all different companies
and it's not going to be ready I mean
it's bananas it's bananas okay
so now that we've been out in the world
in the wild with these electric cars
you take it from me
if you live in a city like la
do not buy a car
that is that can't go more than than
that that is less than 300 miles as
their max range because it's not going
to be real
like they need to fix that where it
they're telling you exactly okay you're
200 miles away you only have 200 on your
thing you are driving a hundred miles so
once you put in I'm gonna go 100 miles
they should tell you on the thing oh
you're not gonna make it because with
your radio on and if you use your radio
it's gonna be this if you if you're
charging your phone like they should
have all that calculated in so you can
get a true sense
of how far you can really go it's crazy
so my car goes it had 260 on the on the
on the mileage usually it says 260. that
ain't real that ain't real
okay it's not real 260 is probably
really like 150.
uh that's probably more accurate with
radio and going up hills and driving on
the freeway and all of these factors man
I'm telling you 260 is not real none of
them cars it's so like Volvo sells a car
that they're they're saying oh go 225
miles what
out that's absurd
to be selling that like that so
it's crazy
you know
oh do I want to show you guys inside the
car oh let me just go back and look at
my car
so look at this let's go inside look at
that you can I love this website the
fact that you could do this I mean isn't
that something
uh wow that's dope look at that so it's
gonna be white interior oh let's open
this oh
anyways I'm opening the trunk and all
that kind of stuff for the people that
are listening it looks crazy so anyways
so this one they claim it goes 350 miles
you know so like I say we'll see
wait
there we go
um anyways all right enough electric
cars
uh it's crazy so I had this thing up
from this pole
um this girl man this was like a a weird
little
a feel-good story so this is cheerleader
in Nebraska right and she
so she her her school who apparently her
school doesn't actually do very well
usually in this competition from when I
when I read the story but like so this
competition's coming up for uh the state
Nebraska cheerleading competition and
like two weeks or so before the
competition
her teammates bail like
everybody quits
and so she decides
I'm gonna just perform on my own
she's like I'm gonna perform on my own
so she goes to the competition does a
routine obviously nobody's even in the
stands does a competition by herself and
out of the 12 teams that showed up to
the competition
she finished eighth which is the highest
her team has
placed in in in the competition ever and
I was like good for her
like would you do that
like if you're on a cheerleading team a
dance team like obviously it can't be
something like basketball or football or
something that you obviously need your
teammates but it's of some kind of
competition where you have a bunch of
teammates you guys get together and then
people just quit on you how would that
make you feel I would love to know what
you guys think in the chat in the
comments so give me your
feeling on that so I put a poll up just
to see I know there must have been
random you guys know what's been what is
this poll even about but it says would
you perform a loan if your cheerleading
team quit and it's crazy that 53 percent
of you said no
so it's like most of you are saying no I
mean isn't that like it's it's like I
guess
so more power to this this girl man
um
what wait what's her name I don't even
know what I don't even get her name what
is her name
uh she's a senior Katrina kohel I don't
know if I'm saying her last name right
but from Morrell High School in Nebraska
I just went to Nebraska so that's why
when I got this you know you travel one
place and then your phone thinks you go
to Nebraska all the time so I'm getting
Nebraska stories but uh yeah shout out
to Katrina good job good job
you know that was great
here's another crazy one
and there's another crazy story that
happened that just I was you ever see a
story that makes you fume that because
you put yourself in that situation and
you'd be like what if this happened to
me so this moving company in Born numis
me mouth I don't know I think this is in
England or someplace let's see where it
is
um yeah Lake Ansel ordered the sofa oh
Lou oh not Lake Luke somebody named Luke
I don't know where they are but
regardless where is wherever bernouf is
I know that dude that always sends me an
email about me get your facts right man
make sure you know stuff before you go
into podcast yeah whatever dude
so check this out
so the moving company
came to like do this okay and they got
the sofa stuck in the stairwell
and they were like they just left they
were like yeah we can't
we can't do it so we're gone
I was like what
dude I and look how they they tried to
look how they jacked up so they this big
leather sofa is just jammed in their
stairwell and then when they finally got
this the sofa you know up the people the
movers had cracked the walls
and tore up the whole place
I mean just just reminded me
of when I moved in
and he's what pissed me off like you you
call the moving company and it's gonna
be whatever dude is there the businessy
nice guy that's giving you the quote and
doing the talk that person is always you
go oh okay because in your mind you go
this kind of people are going to be the
people that are going to be in my place
moving my stuff it's not okay the dudes
just showed up I was like oh no who are
y'all you know what I mean like I'm just
gonna be 100 with it they they
they seem seedy it's the best way I'll
say it okay it just
I was I had to keep my eye on these
dudes the whole time and they broke one
of my tables they broke one of my tables
and didn't tell me check this out these
mother they broke one of my end tables
in the living room one of my living room
tables
and just threw it away and didn't tell
me till like yeah we had to throw that
table away I was like what like what if
it was an antique or what if it meant
something to me I was like oh man
but they still had so much work to do
let me give you some advice from when
you're moving when you're moving and you
call the company okay and they're going
to give you a quote all right and when
they give you this quote it's a lot of
times it's going to be a quote for an
amount of hours
don't believe double that whatever they
say so if they go let's say you have a
two-story house and you move into
another two-story house across town okay
and they say all right well this is a
quote for six hours
don't believe them
don't take that quote for six hours
no house can be moved into in six hours
just you tell it no no I need that same
number for 12 hours and then we'll pay
extra so make sure you have a reasonable
amount of time to for them to pack the
truck unpack the truck and take the
stuff into your place take the stuff out
of your place put it in the truck take
it out of the truck put it in your place
make sure you have a reasonable amount
of time quote for that 10 hours minimum
and then make sure you know how much
it's gonna be if they have to stay
longer
crazy
like can you imagine they trying to move
you in and then they jacking up your
couch your walls now you have to get you
have to have a contractor come in and
fix your walls like
there's no professional moving school
man the dude or lady that runs the
company and they're talking to you and
they're all like oh thank you for using
you know happy day moving and it's
always some dumb ass name like that too
that to trick you you know they'll have
some name like you know good feeling
moving you know uh we always do it right
moving so you think oh okay you you know
you wouldn't name something like that if
if it wasn't true it's never true
they're Liars okay they should be called
Jack yo [__] up moving okay uh be leery
of the people moving moving company it
should be something like that so you
could you know keep your eye on these
people you know and and they and they
mad too because oh man we gotta move all
this did there it's like imagine you
hire a moving company and the people
that are doing the moving or walking in
going like damn you got a lot of stuff
like what this is what you here for
so annoying
so when I saw that story I just was like
immediately
just
flabbergasted and Furious for the people
that were that
on that couch like are you kidding me
man
anyways that's crazy
um
another story I saw is like and this
really pisses me off about how people
are because this just reminds me of
something that happens with my parents
man so they got this fake Girl Scout
cookie sellers are looking to scam money
from unsuspecting buyers
so just like you know people it's like I
you know you you this used to be a thing
for more from my childhood than I think
I don't know tell me in the chat if you
guys
are in the comments too if you're
listening later like
we did you ever interact with Girl
Scouts and boy scouts like it doesn't
seem to be a thing anymore or it doesn't
seem to be a thing that's needed where
like you know you you know you you knock
on people's door or you go door to door
or you even see him out at the
supermarket it doesn't seem to be like
as much as it was before or the things
that I remember you know the Girl Scouts
would come knocking on your door like we
got Girl Scout cookies and you just be
like all right you know give me these
nasty ass cookies and sometimes they're
really good right you'd be like oh okay
these are the jam but a lot of times you
know you're just supporting it's like
buying a Comics t-shirt at a show they
got some dumb thing on the shirt from
their stupid joke and you're just kind
of like all right I'll buy that because
it's really just a tip it's really like
I appreciate you so when you're buying
Girl Scout cookies and whatever are
raffle tickets or the people used to
sell chocolates remember those little
kids would be selling chocolate that's
just for you to just be like all right
whatever little cause this is for I'm
helping you like you all going to Camp
it ain't really for the cookies it's
just kind of like a the cookies are like
a tip for you like hey thanks for
helping us here's some free chocolate
that's really what that's really I look
at it but imagine
people
like taking advantage of like fake Girl
Scout cookies
that's what this story is about in
Raleigh North Carolina you know
lots of people like Girl Scout cookies
so it's not hard to sell them set a Girl
Scout named whatever her name was
um but it apparently
it's like how is that even possible
so the imposters so I guess
I guess you you would get a Girl Scout
outfit for your kid
you know
and then you would just go to Costco
buy some cheap ass cookies
like this seems to be a lot of work like
are you just selling Chips Ahoy or you
like oh like do you have like fake are
you getting fake packaging made like how
are you doing this
seems like a lot of work for this scam
and then they going around knocking on
people's door and being like
hey
bodies cookies I mean well how terrible
is that did you think you you
think you buying Girl Scout cookies from
you know so what are they doing they
just take it like what are they using
the money for like like to me I feel
like all the work you do in to sell
these fake cookies
it's like maybe you need this money more
than me I just I don't know
I don't know I don't even remember what
were the Good Girl Scout cookies do you
guys are do you guys ever remember
let me look it up girl scout
I like what my computer works Girl Scout
cookies yeah you could just buy them at
like that's the thing now too is you
could just get them online like they
have the Girl Scouts Girl Scouts
dot org shout out to the Girl Scouts
organization you know you're doing
cookies and you know they got a whole
website now like everything's online now
so how does this even work
like there's no like I don't even want
somebody coming to my door now even if
it's like a little kid selling stuff I'd
be like yo what what you want
you just like do you want anybody coming
to your door now
I don't know it just seems like
it seems it seems weird to me now uh I I
just I don't know
all right let's see all right so they
got the Girl Scout cookies
they're not showing you the flavors
like can we get the flavors like what's
up with the oh they have one called
raspberry rally now okay
ah they got all these new flavors with
the Girl Scout cookies uh
yeah they did they just won't I don't
you can't this is now they need to work
on their website okay
they need like the Girl Scouts
let's work on this website y'all
when I go to cookies okay
if I click the link cookies
some damn cookies need to come up on the
screen okay all right where the cookies
at
look at this about cookies okay start
here
still no cookies
flavors explore now finally we got to
the cookie flavors man
fat guy problems
all right y'all Girl Scout cookies
raspberry rally okay stop flirting
Adventure fools ooh gluten-free no like
no that's all I have to say about that
caramel delights I don't know what that
is
peanut butter sandwich okay they got a
s'more they got lemons lemonade lemon
UPS peanut butter patties Thin Mints I
don't remember them having all these
flavors before when did they get all
this man I think Thin Mints were to jam
right within Mr Jam toffee-tastic I like
that trufffoils iconic shortbread oh
yeah the shortbread ones are always the
good ones just made it pure sugar well
yeah this website's pretty fascinating
they got the cookie history
so I might actually buy me some cookies
donate to the uh these people
um yeah but get your site together when
I click cookie
take me to the cookies okay
um yeah so I just think I think that's
messed up
people's fake fake Girl Scouts fake
cookies
like like I said where are they getting
these cookies
I don't know it just that that seems
that seems that's some weird stuff right
there y'all that's some weird stuff
all right man let's finish up with
let's finish up the podcast with
um
wait let me do this hold up guys boom
there we go boom
Last of Us that's not the real that's
just from the oh wait cause you got to
go like this you can see them there's
George Pascal and there's the great girl
whatever her name is
let's look it up so I just want to get
caught up on Last of Us y'all it's been
good uh I don't know if you guys have
watched this show it I mean it's a lot
of like I could feel the diversity
meeting if I'm being honest
you know there's just a lot of like oh
this this is gonna be uh one of these
kind of like
we're gonna be making a lot of like
political statements and we're gonna be
like hey we're gonna there's gonna be a
lot of diversity and uh and stuff going
on here but uh let me get the girl's
name Bella Ramsey Bella Ramsey's doing a
good job
it is a really great show
um you know at this point no I'm not
gonna spoil last night's episode
but you know get it together uh you know
so you know there if you don't know what
the show's about if you follow the video
game which I only played the video game
a couple of times it's like whatever you
know but you know they're it's a
post-apocalyptic virus has wiped out
most of society and this is how people
are trying to survive and then it's a
virus that turns people into sort of
zombie monsters and so like there's
little communities of people and and
normally in these kind of like zombie
based shows and movies the real monsters
are human beings like that's the theme
always of any sort of any sort of zombie
movie
you would your takeaway is human beings
are worse than zombies that's just the
facts of it okay
so you get bitten by a zombie and you
turn into a zombie uh whatever they're
called in the show you know and the
little girl spoiler alert just you
should know this by now anyway I mean
you know what I mean like I said I'm not
telling you anything about the the
episodes but you know spoiler the girl's
bitten but she seems to be immune so now
they're trying to get her to like the to
the rebels you know these people who are
called the fireflies and they have
scientists and stuff and they're trying
to finally find a cure for this that
maybe they could save save Humanity all
right so and then it's about this these
two people George Pascal plays you know
what's what's the name of his character
um Joel so it's Joel and and Bella plays
Ellie you know so they're on this
adventure together and he lost his
daughter and you you know and so and
he's just a Broken Man at this point now
who's done some terrible things to
survive and she's this little girl who
grew up in this world of nonsense you
know so she doesn't even know about TV
and everything's like a myth to her and
and they have this Great Bond and
they're on this adventure in this
ravaged land you know and in the midst
of it you meet a bunch of characters and
nobody's safe just FYI
don't get attached to anybody else okay
that's one thing I'll say about this
show
do not get attached
um because they gonna be gone they're
gonna be dead Okay most likely so and
it's like it's it's it's a Well Done
show so you know and so you know I've
talked about it already but now we're at
like episode four or five and you really
are starting to to like them and and
they do a lot of like flashback here's
how we got to this point
a lot of romance a lot of Beautiful
Stories being told
it it's a good show you know I was a big
Walking Dead fan I was and but it just
after a certain time in Walking Dead I
just was done you know like I haven't
watched Walking Dead or even Fear The
Walking Dead the the new spin-off and
stuff it just got to a point where I was
like okay yeah you trying to fight
zombies and but you run into people who
are way worse like that's the theme of
that show and and and wants to they
killed off the characters that you liked
it just became a thing where it's like
all right what new stories can you tell
you know it's like a soap opera
surrounded by zombies but and there's
never enough zombie action that was the
kind of that got me about walking dead
there's never enough zombie action now I
will say this
there ain't enough zombie action in this
show either if that's what you want to
see if you want to see some zombies
eating heads and brains this ain't the
show for that
you know
and so I'm kind of a mixed reviews of
how I feel about that part of it
but these two actors
are doing such a great job that I feel
like you know what it's worth going
along this journey to find out what
you know it's like I'll go on this
journey to find out what's happening in
the end
until we uh you know figure out
what's the end result you know
it's like another show that I'm watching
right now and I really this this is kind
of on the cuff on the Fly
of something uh and I'll probably talk
about it more next week is but I don't
know if anybody's watching this show
servant on Apple TV I really liked the
first
episodes
of servant
uh the first Seasons because it was like
this but now I'm just kind of like
what's happening
I don't know if anybody's watching it
but so maybe I'll
talk about it next week but yeah we're
like Knee Deep and I think it's the last
season and there's just like a key piece
of information in the show that you just
kind of like yo can we get to this
already like it's been four seasons
get to it
uh no I've never watched you and it's
never appealed to me
but if you have a show that you really
like and you think I like because you
watch my podcast all the time you know
send me a little message or put it in
the comments and be like yo Griff check
out this show because there are some
shows I want to watch that that that's
uh coming out now like all the new
stuff's coming out you know new seasons
of shows and stuff like that so the
consultant that's the one I want to
watch actually I want to watch that I'm
going to start watching the consultant
and I'll let you guys know uh what
what's going on with that okay
um but guys uh I appreciate you guys
always being here remember
um we're from with Griffin I'm gonna be
in Vegas this week uh subscribe share
hit the notifications man it really
helps me out I'm gonna be on Twitch
shortly so take take a look I'll be on
there you want to support our patreon I
want to start doing I have to I'm
setting it up I want to start doing like
a more you know like like a morning wake
up where I get up I go live on my from
my patreon YouTube members and twitch
subscribers and then you know that
content will be up there you know and so
yeah so so so keep a look out for that
but you know how we do this y'all you
know how we do this every week with the
robbery cap
shout out to Mr Chris you for another
dope beat
[Music]
tell your friend
when you're cheating team quicks on you
gonna do
keep it going thought you knew
the rain in California
Last of Us is still good
[Music]
well I wish you would
not watch that show they have to after
hearing this flow
check it out Girl Scouts shout about
with those
[Music]
thanks for watching
every week
when you hear this beat you're at home
tapping your feet
Griffin
[Music]
thanks for watching
and when there's a dumb [__] in the
chat
whack ass comments oh he took it back
cause he's a [__]
I'm not 60.
keeping it squishy
rapping this swiftly
[Music]
you a troll ass [__] all up in the chat
got nothing to say cause you back you
wish you was having fun like me I'm
rapping Twitter
don't come back [__]
later
alligator
[Music]
that's how we do it
that was a live SmackDown
all right y'all thanks for being here
I'm ripping with Griffin
yo negative ass [__] don't come back
all right y'all see you next
[Music]